the first ships long delayed by war are
laden with ukrainian grain and ready to
course through a new shipping lane
designed to be safe from the conflict
around it
ukraine hopes that soon it will again be
feeding the world
we sent all the signals to our partners
the un and turkey and our military has
guaranteed the security situation
as farmers continue to harvest this
year's wheat corn and sunflower seeds 25
million tons of grain from last season
had been stuck in storage silos at three
black sea ports
until now
the first trips are a test run after
that more ships will leave from the
ports of odessa chernimorsk and pivdeni
in the coming days
if all goes well
the u.s ambassador joining her group of
seven colleagues in odessa says they are
united in a simple task to get this
grain to the people who need it
to hungry people around the world
and also to shine a spotlight on the
fact
that it's very important for russia to
live up to its commitments and to allow
this grain
to be exported
oleg brindak the deputy mayor of odessa
says the port is a lifeline to a world
struggling to avert a global food crisis
the port of odessa is the oxygen ukraine
needs to breathe it's not only for
odessa we understand the grain is a
strategic raw material for the entire
world this makes it possible today in
ukraine for us to continue fighting and
defend our independence
across ukraine strikes from both sides
are a reminder of the danger of sending
ships through wartime waters
the ukrainian military says russian
forces have leveled a school in
kramatorsk in the east while the russian
defense ministry says a ukrainian
missile struck a prison in olenivka in
the donbas killing dozens of people
keefe says that's disinformation from
the kremlin and that it was actually
russian forces who carried out the
attack
the prisoners of war inside the facility
were from the azov battalion which
became synonymous with ukrainian
strength when its fighters held off
russian forces in mariopol for weeks
john hendren al jazeera odessa ukraine